okay first question do you have CBD oil
on your feet tonight I don't I didn't
put any because I've got a good platform
on tonight so I felt like I think I'm
okay I'm okay I'm okay
and like we sit down a lot it's fine I
think I'll be okay
you are presenting tonight when you see
when you wake up and you see former
president Obama has unbelievable on his
best of lists and book smart and book
smart as well on his best of list hello
Caitlin Deaver ma'am the fact that like
Obama has like watched me in anything is
even if he watched just a trailer of
book smarter unbelievable they would
just say I don't need to do anything I
can I can retire your TV mom and dad
were on with us the other day and they
were saying how just how freaking proud
they are yeah Tim and Nancy we're on
just how proud they are of you and
everything you do it really has been a
great year for you do you feel like yeah
I'm kind of coming into my stride now I
don't know it's always been I think
maybe I'll be able to sort of react to
everything that's happened maybe six
months from now because I'm still sort
of in it oh and it feels just I feel
just very excited and that I feel very
lucky how did you get your sag card Oh
God
probably a go-gurt commercial like it
was definitely a commercial yeah
definitely a commercial sided I was I
was good at those at the very beginning
I did a lot of them before my first
movie yeah okay tell me about this dress
you were princess at the Golden Globes
and now we're going sleek in six yes it
was it was a decision that I that I made
with Carla Welsh my stylist she's just
the greatest it is great she's just I
love her so much she just gets on
Instagram and everything so I mean yeah
IIIi would follow her if she wasn't my
stylist she's the best but no I was you
know wanted to do something a little
sparkly I'm presenting tonight it's my
second time third I guess it's my third
time presenting and I still get nervous
let's play a little fashion scorecard
okay all right before putting on this
dress I was wearing sweatpants from the
men's department and and a yellow shirt
with a teddy bear on it oversized well
you don't have a person with you tonight
but do you carry a clutch I do what's a
must that you always have to have in
your class blotting papers thing that
can go well tonight because it's a
little fishy fishy how do you say that
stitch fits pitching tell me something
cool and what you like most about your
look to me I kind of feel great in it
because it feels like an it just feels
like a nightgown and I feel very cozy in
it that the Globes dress was itchy on
the inside but I feel like I feel like I
can move this one party tonight
Kaitlyn can party tonight I love that so
good to see you
[Music]